J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Bonjour Internet, on se retrouve cette semaine pour une nouvelle interview politique, cette fois-ci avec celui qui est le numéro deux du Parti du Travail de Belgique, David Pestieau.
Pour rappel, le PTB, parti d'extrême gauche présent autant au nord qu'au sud du pays, est placé très haut dans tous les sondages et aura vraisemblablement un rôle très important à jouer au lendemain des élections du 9 juin prochain.
Dans le contexte politique et économique actuel et dans la crise de la démocratie,
que nous traversons depuis quelque temps déjà et dans une société de plus en plus polarisée, comme on a eu l'occasion d'en discuter un paquet de fois dans des épisodes précédents,
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que les scores de popularité des extrêmes sont en hausse.
Du côté francophone, l'extrême droite est relativement inexistante. C'est une chance
assez exceptionnelle en Europe et un facteur important pour l'expliquer est très certainement le respect que nos médias ont accordé historiquement au cordon sanitaire.
Sur cette idée, moi, j'essaye de faire le tour du paysage politique avant ces élections, mais voilà, j'annonce directement la couleur, je ne vais pas inviter une personnalité de la N-VA ou du Vlaams Belang.
Je le dis tout de suite, Dries Van Langenhove ne viendra pas dans Septante Minutes Avec. C'était mon poisson d'avril d'ailleurs il y a quelques semaines, pour ceux qui l'ont vu.
N'hésitez pas à me suivre sur Instagram d'ailleurs, pour de la farce de haute qualité. Et certains, chez les libéraux notamment, de défendre l'idée que le PTB devrait être écarté de la même manière.
Personnellement, je pense absolument pas que ce soit une bonne idée. Je pense que c'est le genre de plan qui contribue à mettre de l'huile sur le feu et à amplifier la polarisation que j'évoquais il y a un instant.
Et j'assume pleinement mon choix d'avoir invité le PTB dans mon podcast. Tout d'abord parce que, comme je le disais, ils sont sur le point de devenir un acteur majeur sur la scène politique belge.
Et ensuite, parce que si l'anticapitalisme et le marxisme parviennent à séduire de plus en plus de monde, notamment chez les jeunes, mais vraiment à travers toutes les classes sociales,
ça montre que, je pense, tout ça prend racine sur de réelles injustices et sur une frustration grandissante de la population.
Je vous refais pas le tableau. Voilà, on en parle presque un épisode sur deux.
Mais bref, je trouvais que c'était essentiel de se pencher le temps de Septante Minutes Avec le directeur politique du parti pour comprendre ce qui fait l'essence du PTB, finalement.
Je pense que c'était une bonne interview. Vous allez voir que comme pour mes invités précédents, j'ai évidemment fait en sorte de challenger mon invité, de le mettre en difficulté.
Et il a joué le jeu, on peut lui reconnaître ça et il a été très cordial et je le remercie pour ça. Je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute.
J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec David Pestieau. Bonjour David.
Bonjour.
David Pestieau, vous êtes Bruxellois, même si vous êtes né aux États-Unis. Vous êtes militant depuis votre adolescence pour le PTB.
Vous avez toujours travaillé d'ailleurs pour le PTB. Vous êtes aujourd'hui directeur de son centre d'études. Vous êtes également l'auteur de We are one, manifeste pour l'unité de la Belgique, votre livre.
Et enfin, vous êtes huitième candidat effectif pour le PTB aux élections européennes en juin. Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
Non, c'est parfait.
C'est parfait ? Magnifique.
J'ai travaillé à l'ULB. J'ai été assistant à l'ULB pendant quatre ans.
Ah oui, OK, OK. Mais pendant ce temps-là, vous étiez aussi actif au PTB.
Oui.
Et en parallèle, effectivement, vous avez occupé d'autres fonctions, en dehors du parti.
Voilà.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas pour tout le monde. On va avoir le temps, du coup, aujourd'hui, de plonger au cœur de ce qui fait du PTB le PTB.
Mais avant de se plonger là-dedans, on va revenir l'espace d'un instant sur l'actualité récente, puisqu'on enregistre ce podcast le 18 avril,
le lendemain d'un vote qui apparemment est qualifié d'historique, puisque le PTB a voté en commission avec Ecolo et le Parti socialiste pour,
disons, mettre un terme ou abroger le décret Paysage.
Est-ce que vous rejoignez Georges-Louis Bouchez lorsqu'il explique que c'est aujourd'hui Raoul Hedebouw qui est le patron de la gauche en Belgique francophone ?
Non, je pense pas. Je pense que la gauche en Belgique, elle est diverse. Je pense simplement que ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'il y a eu d'abord un mouvement étudiant très important qui s'est opposé à un décret qui était élitiste.
Il touche surtout des étudiants qui sont précarisés, qui doivent souvent faire un job pour faire leurs études et qui, par là, bon, plus difficile à terminer leurs études dans les temps impartis.
Ce mouvement a été, je pense,
a déjà commencé depuis 2021, depuis le moment où la réforme a été votée, mais il est clair qu'aujourd'hui, la réforme est en train de montrer sa pratique
et que c'est à partir de là que des milliers, des milliers d'étudiants se sont inquiétés, se sont mobilisés
et ont finalement imposé que ce thème revienne à l'agenda du Parlement et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui, non pas que le décret a été abrogé, mais qu'il a été amendé et en tout cas, pour la prochaine année a été—
Pour la prochaine année, c'est ça, voilà.
A été revu. Mais donc, c'est d'abord le, je pense—
Mesure temporaire, ouais.
Je pense qu'au-delà, je dirais même avant la discussion sur... Sur ces questions politiques, il y a
le fait qu'un mouvement étudiant, et c'est la même chose pour d'autres mouvements sociaux, permet, s'il y a un débat de société, de remettre en cause des choses qui paraissent inévitables.
La loi, c'est la loi. La loi a été votée. Aujourd'hui, c'est un nouvel exemple que quand il y a un mouvement social, eh ben, une loi peut être revue, et peut être même abrogée.
Ça, c'est en tout cas, je pense, le souhait des étudiants, en tout cas d'une partie des étudiants aujourd'hui, que cette réforme élitiste soit revue.
Et donc, ce sera le sujet de la prochaine séance plénière au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, puisque donc, il a passé le stade de la commission, la première étape.
Il a pas encore été voté, mais tout indique que les mêmes acteurs vont maintenir leur vote. Et finalement, la seule question, c'est : est-ce que le Mouvement Réformateur changera sa position ?
Ce qui, au vu des acteurs concernés, est peu probable. Mais dans tous les cas, c'est la dernière séance plénière pour cette législation.
Donc, voilà, les enjeux pour la coalition sont relativement faibles. Est-ce que ça vous choque malgré tout, que deux partis puissent revenir sur le texte que eux-mêmes avaient voté à l'origine ?
Et certains utilisent le mot de trahison, vis-à-vis de leurs partenaires du gouvernement. Est-ce que ça vous paraît correct en termes de, voilà, de professionnalisme, de sérieux politique, diront certains ?
Non, je pense que c'est, comme je le dis, je pense que c'est le résultat d'un mouvement social. Il y a énormément d'étudiants
qui sont confrontés avec la réalité qu'ils pourraient ne plus être financés au prochain, à la prochaine année.
Ils sont très inquiets, d'autres sont solidaires de leurs condisciples, on va dire, et se sont mis en mouvement.
Et donc ça amène à ce que certains politiques qui avaient d'abord voté pour la réforme, en tout cas au PS et Écolo, ils ont voté cette réforme.
Nous avons averti à l'époque de manière très claire que cette réforme allait produire ces effets-là. Le mouvement étudiant l'avait aussi avancé.
À ce moment-là, on n'a pas été entendu. Et aujourd'hui, on a été entendu, je pense, parce qu'il y a eu une pression d'en bas, il y a une pression de la population.
Et c'est ça qui a fait réfléchir, je pense, beaucoup d'élus de ces partis-là. Et puis évidemment, il y a les élections qui approchent.
Et donc évidemment, c'était impossible pour eux de résister à cette pression, de finalement changer d'avis. Je pense que c'est bien qu'ils ont changé d'avis.
C'est comme ça que je pense que s'écrit l'histoire. Parce que si chaque fois, l'histoire s'écrivait simplement parce que,
des états-majors ont décidé de réformes, etc., on n'aurait pas eu beaucoup de changements en Belgique hein.
Est-ce que donc c'est le résultat d'un mouvement social ? Ou est-ce que ce sont les élections qui arrivent dans six semaines qui ont, qui ont mené, à votre avis, Ecolo et le Parti socialiste à retourner leur veste ?
Je pense que c'est d'abord le résultat d'un mouvement social.
C'est ce qu'ils disent.
Oui, je pense que c'est d'abord le résultat d'un mouvement social. Après, je pense que le fait de pouvoir peut-être se faire sanctionner par une nouvelle génération de primo-votants a joué aussi.
Qui est significative pour ces élections, qui pèsent beaucoup.
Bien sûr. Et je pense que ça a joué énormément. Et je pense que l'expérience que les étudiants ont eue est très instructive au niveau politique.
Parce qu'à partir du moment où on voit des partis, le MR a été constant, a été cohérent dans sa vision d'un enseignement élitiste seulement ouvert aux gens qui n'ont jamais de problèmes, qui sont,
des étudiants qui sont issus de milieux plutôt aisés.
Ça a été cohérent. Puis le PTB a été cohérent. Et puis, on a vu, dans l'autre sens, défendant l'idée d'un enseignement démocratique dans l'esprit, je crois, de Mai 68.
Et puis, de l'autre côté, on a vu des partis qui ont fait le yo-yo, qui ont été d'abord pour la réforme et puis qui, après, ont dit : Non, on demande le retrait de la réforme.
Donc, le vingt-sept mars, et le PS et Ecolo demandent le retrait de la réforme et soutiennent la proposition de la FEF.
Et puis finalement, aboutissent à quelque chose qui est entre les deux, qui est un moratoire. C'est déjà quelque chose de bien, c'est positif qu'on a cette avancée, mais qui n'est pas la demande que les étudiants ont porté initialement.
Je vais juste préciser quelque chose par rapport à ce que vous venez de dire, c'est que vous décrivez le texte comme étant favorable, donc, aux étudiants les plus favorisés, les plus privilégiés, les plus riches.
Il existait dans ce décret un article spécifiquement pour les étudiants en situation de précarité pour leur permettre de rallonger, puisque le texte du décret Paysage
voulait faire en sorte qu'on devait valider ces soixante crédits absolument sur deux ans maximum, et sinon, on perdait son statut d'étudiant finançable.
Il existait un article, quelque part dans le texte, pour spécifiquement les étudiants qui avaient un statut précaire pour pouvoir leur demander une exception et pouvoir éventuellement rallonger la durée de leurs études.
Oui, mais c'était un peu pour la forme, parce qu'il y a tellement d'étudiants qui sont dans une situation précaire.
Donc, quand vous avez aujourd'hui— moi, je viens d'une génération où il y avait le travail étudiant, le job étudiant, mais c'était encore quelque chose de limité.
Aujourd'hui, un étudiant sur trois fait un job pour pouvoir payer ses études, parfois deux. C'est lié au pouvoir d'achat, c'est lié à la difficulté d'arriver à faire les études.
Il y a une augmentation aussi en dix ans de vingt-sept pour cent du nombre d'étudiants qui font des demandes d'une bourse.
Donc, on est dans une situation, la précarité, elle augmente. Et par rapport à ça, le fait qu'on sait qu'un étudiant qui job a deux fois moins de chances de réussir son année, donc c'est quand même assez important.
Donc il y a des études qui le montrent, parce que vous avez simplement moins de temps pour étudier.
Bien sûr.
Vous êtes dans une situation où vous devez aider, vous devez...
Pouvoir aider ça. Or, et c'est ça qui est remarquable dans la réforme aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on est en train de nous dire : il faut écouter les recteurs, il faut écouter le monde académique.
Moi, j'ai l'impression qu'on l'écoute quand on veut. Parce que quand les recteurs ont demandé il y a deux ans qu'on refinance l'enseignement supérieur cent cinquante millions, on les a envoyés se promener.
Et pourtant, il faut un refinancement pour pouvoir avoir des profs, pour aider à la remédiation, pour avoir de l'aide et offrir des bourses à ceux qui le demandent, etc.
Donc, on ne peut pas d'un côté dire : écoutez, il faut que les gens réussissent, mais ne pas donner les moyens pour que les gens réussissent.
Ça, c'est le problème aujourd'hui de l'enseignement. Et dans la vision du MR, je pense que c'est assez clair dans la manière dont ils l'ont formulé, c'est quelque part, ceux qui veulent peuvent réussir, ceux qui ne travaillent pas ne réussissent pas.
Donc c'est une sorte de mythe de la méritocratie. Alors qu'aujourd'hui, on sait que l'enseignement est à deux vitesses, qu'on a un enseignement
de classe, qu'on a déjà une sélection sociale phénoménale pour les gens qui arrivent à l'université.
Donc il y a une grande majorité des gens qui sont issus des classes aisées et une, en tout cas une sous-représentation des classes populaires, mais qu'en plus, l'environnement universitaire aggrave ces inégalités.
Et donc, si vous, en plus, vous placez des réformes qui vont aggraver, qui vont raccourcir le temps pour lequel on peut faire des études alors qu'on a des difficultés à les terminer parce qu'on fait des jobs, oui, là évidemment,
on favorise un certain nombre de gens, et on a entendu des choses.
Enfin, moi, je trouve ça aberrant, du genre : il ne faut pas que trop de gens réussissent parce que c'est la dévalorisation des diplômes.
Mais là, on est vraiment dans l'élitisme le pur et dur. Et contre ça, c'est l'engagement, je crois, de générations et de générations d'étudiants depuis soixante-huit, de permettre l'accès au plus grand nombre des études supérieures.
C'est un combat gauche-droite, c'est un combat démocratique. Et nous, on l'a porté, on a été conséquents dans ce combat.
Oui, ça touche à la question de l'ascension sociale.
Et je rajouterais par rapport à ce que vous avez dit
que le nombre d'étudiants en situation de précarité ne sont pas forcément au courant qu'il existe des bourses, qu'il existe des aides disponibles pour les étudiants, qu'il existe, voilà, je veux dire,
un article dans le décret Paysage.
Voilà, les étudiants concernés ne sont même pas forcément au courant qu'il existe ces aides, le cas échéant.
Enfin, dernier aspect dans tout ça, c'est la question des chiffres, puisque vous disiez énormément d'étudiants, de plus en plus d'étudiants en situation de précarité.
Je pense qu'un élément important dans cette saga politique et médiatique, ça a été le fait que, notamment, le syndicat étudiant, la FEF, avançait des chiffres qui sont aujourd'hui sérieusement remis en question.
Le fameux, je crois que c'était septante mille étudiants en situation de... qui ne seraient plus finançables, qui seraient éjectés, du coup, des universités.
Ce qui a causé évidemment une grande panique. Ce qui a fait que le Parti socialiste et Écolo étaient un petit peu dos au mur et se sentaient responsables d'une, voilà, d'une catastrophe, surtout dans le contexte des élections.
Et puis, ces chiffres sont de plus en plus remis en question et on dit : Mais non, mais la FEF... Voilà, dans certaines publications, dans certains,
certains médias, on va lire que la FEF est gangrenée par les communistes et que tout ça est une saga qui a été maîtrisée de bout en bout par,
les communistes, par le PTB, et que le Parti socialiste et Écolo sont finalement tombés dans un piège.
Ouais, je pense que c'est un récit assez classique dans un mouvement social de tirer sur le messager et de ne pas voir qu'il y a un problème.
Donc, il y a des milliers et des milliers de témoignages de gens qui sont en difficulté, des milliers de témoignages.
Est-ce qu'on a des chiffres objectifs ?
Mais les chiffres, donc c'est ça qui est incroyable, c'est que d'abord, un, il y a des témoignages et une réalité que des gens se sont mis en mouvement parce qu'ils se sentaient inquiets pour leur propre situation.
Et on n'a pas trouvé un ou deux témoignages, on en a trouvé des centaines. Des centaines directs. Et on a reçu des mails par milliers de gens qui ont dit : Nous sommes inquiets par rapport à telle et telle situation.
Donc ça, c'est un. Deux, ce que la FEF a fait. Donc, précisons ce qu'elle a dit. La FEF a dit : Il y a septante mille étudiants qui risquent de ne pas être dans les critères pour être finançables dans les cinq ans qui viennent.
Donc septante mille divisé par cinq, faites le compte, et qui risquent. Oui, quand on regarde les chiffres par rapport à ce qu'ils ont rassemblé.
Et pourquoi ils ont dû rassembler eux-mêmes les chiffres ? Parce que la ministre, jusqu'aujourd'hui, ne veut pas donner les chiffres.
Donc, on l'a— Et je vais le dire, c'est un adversaire politique qui l'a dit encore ce matin, les chiffres existent.
Il faut les rassembler. Il faut aller dans chaque université et il faut aller les rassembler et les amener devant... Mais madame Bertieaux ne veut pas donner les chiffres.
Et il y a un élément qui a été très intéressant dans la séquence actuelle, c'est qu'on nous a dit que le fait qu'on allait reporter en partie la réforme pour l'année à venir allait coûter, d'après le PS et Écolo, cinq millions.
Mais Bertieaux, la ministre du MR, a prétendu que c'était trente-trois millions. Donc ça veut dire trente-trois millions d'euros.
Ça veut dire que trente-trois millions d'euros, si vous regardez au niveau de la finançabilité, c'est des milliers et des milliers d'étudiants qui sont financés avec ça.
Ça veut dire qu'il y a un impact de milliers et de milliers de personnes. On ne parle pas d'anecdotes, on parle de gens.
Et d'ailleurs, la mesure a ce but. La mesure et la réforme Glatigny, la réforme du décret Paysage, votée à l'époque par le PS, MR et Écolo, a une fonction
de limiter la finançabilité des étudiants parce qu'il y a une enveloppe fermée et parce qu'on veut faire des économies.
Ça, c'est la réalité derrière les chiffres dont on parle. C'est qu'on veut économiser parce qu'on a un enseignement qu'on veut rendre de plus en plus élitiste, limité à un nombre limité de gens.
Oui. Dans le contexte aussi d'une Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles qui est en déficit depuis très très longtemps. Mais là, on touche aux questions institutionnelles, on touche, voilà, encore un autre problème.
Mais je retiens donc la critique du manque de transparence et le fait qu'il y a un certain élitisme et un manque de présence des classes populaires.
On reviendra sur ces notions peut-être un peu plus tard dans l'émission. Mais donc, comme je le disais, on va parler aujourd'hui du PTB.
Alors, pour retracer un petit peu l'histoire, le PTB est un parti qui se définit au sens propre comme étant fondamentalement un parti révolutionnaire.
Historiquement, donc, 1970, la création de TPO, Tout le Pouvoir aux Ouvriers, ou AMADA, Alle Macht Aan De Arbeiders, qui devient donc en 1979 le PTB slash PVDA, Parti du Travail de Belgique.
Le parti donc et son cofondateur Ludo Martens se réclament pendant plusieurs décennies ouvertement du maoïsme et du stalinisme.
Et puis, il y a, voilà, une série de congrès, notamment celui de 2008, qui vont un petit peu repenser différentes doctrines, l'attachement aux différentes doctrines communistes, politiques.
Et voilà, il y avait notamment une sortie en 2012 de Raoul Hedebouw qui disait que face au matraquage idéologique, le PTB s'était enfermé dans le dogmatisme pour maintenir l'existence de l'organisation.
Et voilà, aujourd'hui, régulièrement, le PTB se distancie du stalinisme et se distancie du maoïsme. Ça reste évidemment un parti fondamentalement marxiste.
Quelles sont les étiquettes, quels sont les mots qui vous conviennent aujourd'hui pour définir le PTB ?
Et quels sont éventuellement les États, les États-nations qui vous inspirent comme exemple ?
Alors, je pense que c'est important qu'on voit un peu l'évolution qu'on a eue comme parti. Donc, on est un parti qui s'est construit effectivement après 68, qui a été fondé par des étudiants, qui se sont
lancés, qui étaient dans le cadre
de la guerre du Vietnam, qui se sont radicalisés dans une critique du capitalisme.
C'est... Et donc le PTB de l'époque est le produit de cette période de 68, courant très à gauche,
et c'est, qui a essayé de se démarquer et se construire, forcément, comme quelque chose d'à part, dans la société belge,
avec évidemment, voilà, les, on va dire,
les maux de croissance de l'époque et les défauts de l'époque où effectivement, et certainement dans les années 90, 80, 90 et début des années 2000, souffraient d'un dogmatisme et d'un sectarisme évident.
Donc c'est par rapport à ça qu'il y a eu une mue, un changement, dans l'approche du PTB pour en faire un parti,
je pense d'abord, un, orienté sur la situation en Belgique d'abord, partant des problèmes des gens en Belgique et en même temps gardant l'idée fondamentale qu'il faut contester le capitalisme et qu'il faut s'inspirer du marxisme.
Mmh.
Là, je pense que c'est un peu la combinaison des deux. Donc un parti de principe, mais un parti qui est souple, un parti qui parle, qui part des problèmes des gens.
Donc ça, c'est un peu, disons, la voie qu'on a voulu suivre dans, on va dire, les quinze dernières années et qui a fait qu'on a grandi comme on a grandi.
On va en parler. On va parler de cette croissance, en effet. Mais donc, première question, est-ce qu'il y a des États-nations, des pays qui vous inspirent comme étant des exemples, en disant : ça, on aimerait bien reproduire ?
Non, certainement pas. Je pense que c'est, je pense que ça, c'est aussi un aspect très important de notre renouveau, hein, ce qu'on a appelé le renouveau du PTB, c'était qu'au lieu de
de se référer constamment au passé ou à l'étranger, il fallait définir une voie au XXIe siècle du socialisme en Belgique.
Et que à partir de là, on devait évidemment s'inspirer, et d'aller à l'étranger pour voir, tiens, qu'est-ce qui s'y fait et y apprendre, mais qu'on devait le faire à notre sauce et qu'on vivait ici en Belgique, dans un pays
tel qu'il est et qu'on partait de cette réalité-là pour définir ce que c'est, une voie d'émancipation des travailleurs et des travailleuses en Belgique.
Oui. Alors, vous le disiez, donc le parti a beaucoup grandi ces quinze dernières années, hein.
En 2014, il obtient 3,72 % des voix aux élections fédérales, ce qui lui permet d'arriver pour la première fois à la Chambre des représentants, première fois de son histoire.
Les deux sièges, donc, de Raoul Hedebouw, qu'on connaît bien, et Marco Van Hees, qu'on connaît aussi. En 2019, vous passez à 8,62 % des voix, ce qui vous amène à douze sièges.
Et dans six semaines, on vous prédit jusqu'à environ 19 % des voix en Wallonie et à Bruxelles, ce qui vous placerait en tête-à-tête avec le MR et devant Ecolo et les Engagés, en Région wallonne.
Et certains vous promettent, enfin, certains sondages vous promettent le leadership en Région bruxelloise après les élections.
Évidemment, on verra ce que ça donne. Rien n'est joué à ce stade. Mais, voilà, certains sondages vous placeraient même en tête-à-tête aussi avec la N-VA à la Chambre des représentants, en termes de nombre de sièges.
La question, c'est : qu'est-ce qui explique cette incroyable croissance ces quinze dernières années ? Vous avez donné un début de réponse avec le renouveau, le renouveau idéologique, le renouveau politique.
C'est vous, hein, le directeur politique du PTB. Est-ce que c'est à vous qu'on doit cette incroyable croissance ?
Non, non, absolument pas. Je pense que c'est un travail collectif qui est très riche. Donc, on est passés d'un peu plus d'un millier de membres au tournant des années 2000 à vingt-cinq mille membres aujourd'hui.
Donc oui, c'est en forte croissance.
Je pense qu'il y a eu ce renouveau, hein, qui était important, donc, de partir de la question, du problème des gens, de s'appuyer sur
notre activité dans les maisons médicales, dans les quartiers, dans les entreprises.
Je pense que ça, ça a été un élément important. On va dire ça, c'est notre élément subjectif. Et puis, il y a aussi eu la situation économique et sociale qui a évolué.
On a eu quelques crises qui se sont succédé depuis 2008. On a d'abord eu une crise financière où, je crois que depuis la chute du mur de Berlin, il y a eu pour la première fois l'idée que peut-être le système capitaliste était à mettre en cause.
On a relu Marx dans beaucoup d'endroits pour essayer d'expliquer cette crise qui s'emparait du capitalisme financier.
On a eu la crise de l'euro. On a eu cette crise climatique qui, de plus en plus, a été liée aussi au mode de production capitaliste qui s'est révélée.
Et puis, on a eu la succession en 2020 et puis en 2022, d'une crise du sanitaire, puis qui a eu des conséquences sociales majeures et puis d'une crise énergétique liée à une crise des relations internationales.
Donc, il y a beaucoup de crises qui se cristallisent et qui amènent les gens à remettre en cause des idées qu'ils avaient jusqu'ici, qui étaient bien établies.
Et je pense que le PTB donne une offre politique,
pour essayer de donner à la fois un débouché politique à une colère qui existe chez les gens,
une méfiance qu'ils ont vis-à-vis des politiques, une colère par rapport à leur situation sociale et économique, mais aussi un espoir par rapport à des changements qui sont proposés et à une manière de les proposer aussi.
J'ai insisté sur la question du mouvement social. Pour nous, c'est très important. Et aussi à une forme d'organisation qui est quand même très différente des partis traditionnels, c'est-à-dire une organisation qui est active
tout le long des législatures, qui ne se limite pas à mobiliser sa base juste avant les élections pour faire des voix et puis après,
se replie sur des cabinets ministériels ou sur des attachés parlementaires, mais qui est sur le terrain
chaque année, chaque mois, chaque jour, que ce soit élection ou pas élection.
Alors, je vous rejoins effectivement sur le fait qu'il y a une frustration grandissante, un mécontentement, le besoin de repenser, en tout cas, notre système économique.
Voilà, il y a de plus en plus, notamment chez les jeunes, un anticapitalisme grandissant. Un élément que vous n'avez pas cité, pour expliquer cette incroyable croissance ces quinze dernières années,
sont les environ trois millions d'euros dépensés sur Facebook pendant cette législature.
Est-ce que vous reconnaissez que c'est un facteur important dans votre croissance ?
Je pense que ça a participé à faire connaître notre point de vue et certainement au nord du pays. Donc, il faut savoir qu'on a quand même un grand défi.
On est un parti unitaire, on est un parti qui est actif au nord, au sud et au centre du pays. Nous avons fait une percée, comme vous l'avez décrit, dès 2014, au sud du pays.
Cette percée, on a commencé à la faire en 2019, au nord du pays, dans un contexte politique plus difficile.
Il faut reconnaître que s'imposer comme un parti dans une Flandre où on a une extrême droite qui est à 18 pour cent, une droite nationaliste qui est à vingt-cinq.
Ouais, ce n'est pas évident, évident. Donc, on doit redoubler d'efforts. Je le dis toujours, un vote arraché en Flandre, ça en vaut trois au sud du pays, façon de parler.
Donc, c'est un combat difficile. Et oui, donc, de ce point de vue là, oui, le fait qu'on a investi de l'argent
dans les réseaux sociaux pour aller faire connaître notre point de vue et pour apporter un récit, un narratif différent que celui de l'extrême droite a été très important.
Il faut savoir qu'en Flandre, il y a une colère des gens, mais que cette colère, elle est captée en partie par l'extrême droite qui oriente les gens tout le jour vers le bas, les chômeurs, les immigrés, les Wallons.
Et nous, on essaie d'orienter cette colère vers le haut.
Vous répondez donc sur la Flandre. Vous êtes également champion en Belgique francophone de dépenses sur Facebook. Comparé aux autres partis.
C'est en train de changer assez drastiquement. Donc, pour l'instant...
En progression, oui.
De manière assez récente, je pense que les Engagés, le MR et même le Parti socialiste nous ont dépassés les derniers mois.
Donc, ça montre bien qu'ils avaient probablement sous-estimé la force de ce média. Et je pense que c'est important d'investir les médias sociaux de manière générale.
Vous expliquez cette différence par une erreur stratégique des autres partis ?
Je pense qu'il y a... ça fait... Si vous comparez les deux, il se fait que nous sommes le seul parti actif des deux côtés de la barrière linguistique.
Il n'y a pas photo. Je veux dire, l'activité sur les réseaux sociaux, elle était encore dans ses petits souliers côté francophone, quand elle était déjà fort développée côté néerlandophone.
Et oui, donc évidemment, nous étions quelque part un peu en avance côté francophone par rapport à ça.
Est-ce que vous seriez donc favorable, puisque vous présentez la chose comme étant finalement une contrainte. Vous êtes obligé, d'après vous, de dépenser autant d'argent sur Facebook parce que sinon, vous n'existez pas médiatiquement pour ainsi dire.
Vous êtes dans l'impossibilité de vous faire connaître. Est-ce que vous êtes alors en faveur de plafonner ces dépenses sur Facebook et sur les réseaux sociaux comme ça a déjà été proposé ?
Non, parce que je pense que ce que les partis font de leur argent, c'est les partis qui décident ce qu'ils y font. Donc aujourd'hui, il faut quand même savoir, enfin, je veux dire, il faut regarder même la télévision francophone.
J'ai pris l'exemple de la télévision néerlandophone parce qu'elle est flagrante. Mais du côté francophone, vous voyez la tête de monsieur Boucher et de monsieur Magnette trois à quatre fois plus souvent que celle de monsieur Hedebouw.
Pourquoi ? Parce que oui, il y a une prime à ceux qui sont au gouvernement. Il y a une prime aux grands partis traditionnels qu'on a toujours eus.
Et donc ça reste une sous-exposition
assez forte. Tant qu'il y a cette différence, qu'il n'y a pas d'égalité d'accès à l'antenne et deuxièmement, qu'il n'y a pas de réseaux sociaux qui, effectivement, donnent un accès égal à tout le monde, oui, on doit faire avec ce qu'il y a.
Donc moi, si je pouvais avoir autre chose, je ferais avec autre chose. Maintenant, je suis dans cette réalité-là, je ne peux pas faire autrement.
On ne peut pas faire autrement que ce qu'on fait maintenant.
On peut plafonner.
On peut plafonner, mais alors à ce moment-là, on va demander, et c'est ce qu'on demande régulièrement, un accès équitable aux médias.
Et si on a un accès équitable aux médias, ce qui n'est pas le cas, on peut discuter de tout.
Oui, oui. Et alors, ça pose la question, donc, accès équitable aux médias, alors, pour tous les partis. Et ça pose la question du cordon sanitaire médiatique qui est absent, donc, en Flandre, mais qui est présent au sud du pays.
Donc c'est une question peut-être plus compliquée que ce qu'il en a l'air.
Oui, ça fait partie de... Donc, il y a un cordon médiatique au sud du pays qu'on défend, on l'a défendu.
Il se fait qu'en Flandre, ça n'existe plus, c'est pas de notre faute. Et donc, à partir de là, oui, pour nous, il y a-
Donc est-ce qu'on peut défendre l'exigence d'avoir un accès équitable pour tous les partis et en même temps-
Oui, oui, mais dans le cordon, le cordon médiatique est lié à des raisons précises, c'est-à-dire le fait que des partis qui prônent la haine et le racisme ne peuvent pas participer au débat politique côté francophone.
Et je pense que c'est une bonne chose, parce que c'est... Pour moi, c'est pas une opinion, c'est un délit. Donc, j'ai toujours, on a toujours défendu ça, mais dans un contexte où le rapport de force n'est pas là.
C'est clair qu'en Flandre, voilà, on ne serait pas contre le fait d'avoir... On veut, on doit lutter avec la réalité devant laquelle on est.
Si en Flandre, aujourd'hui, le Vlaams Belang est à 18 %, c'est dommage, c'est même souvent pénible, mais, nous, on doit faire en sorte qu'ils ne grandissent pas et qu'il y ait une place pour une gauche authentique.
Alors, chaque année, la Commission financière du Conseil National présente un rapport financier et un budget au Conseil National du PTB.
Est-ce qu'il y a une transparence sur les sources de la trésorerie et les dépenses du parti qui permettent donc ces investissements sur les réseaux sociaux ?
Puisque vous parliez de transparence il y a quelques instants.
Oui, mais donc d'abord, nos comptes sont déposés au Parlement, chaque année, avec une ventilation qui est expliquée, qui explique d'ailleurs que nous sommes le parti qui dépensons le plus, en termes de,
de personnes employées par le parti, hein, proportionnellement au budget, au budget.
Donc, on investit énormément dans notre travail d'étude, notre travail de terrain, notre travail d'encadrement. Donc, c'est quelque chose qu'on fait.
Évidemment, on ne paye pas les gens comme au MR. On ne donne pas dix-huit mille euros à son président de parti. Donc oui, évidemment, ça donne plus de possibilités d'engager des gens.
Mais, donc, on est dans une logique, je pense, de... On l'a déjà dit, nous avons défendu le fait que nous sommes en fait pour la diminution de moitié des dotations.
Ça, voilà. Donc, à partir de là, ce serait la première forme de diminuer chez tout le monde l'espèce de subsidiation très forte de la politique en Belgique qui était totalement excessive.
Donc ça, on l'a dénoncé, on l'a avancé. Et chaque fois, on n'a pas trouvé beaucoup d'alliés au Parlement pour défendre ça.
Donc ça a chaque fois été rejeté.
Mais deux, nous appuyons, nous défendons notre modèle, c'est-à-dire un modèle où une partie du financement vient des contributions, des cotisations de nos membres, des dons de nos sympathisants, du fait de notre travail de terrain.
Nous, on pense qu'on doit avoir un système,
ce qu'on voit en Allemagne, le match funding, c'est-à-dire que pour un euro investi par l'État dans un parti, parce que oui, il faut une certaine dotation pour le public, hein, pour stimuler la démocratie, il faut un euro aussi qui vient
d'un travail de terrain, qui vient d'une contribution privée.
Et ceux qui défendent le plus le modèle actuel de subside total de l'État sont les partis libéraux, ce qui est quand même un grand paradoxe. C'est-à-dire que-
Ils en profitent.
Le parti qui dit partout qu'il faut pas investir l'argent de l'État, etc. C'est le parti qui prône-
Le libre marché.
C'est le parti qui reçoit quasiment nonante pourcents de ces fonds par les dotations publiques.
Les autres partis sont un peu moins parce que, voilà, ils ont des rétrocessions, des cotisations. Et le PTB est quasiment à cinquante pourcents de rétrocessions, cotisations et dons,
de sympathisants quand on voit son budget total qui est déposé, qui peut être consulté au Parlement.
Ok. Et donc, ces dons viennent des membres du PTB qui sont issus de classes populaires, qui gagnent un revenu très faible ?
Ou bien est-ce que vous avez parmi vos donateurs des gens peut-être un peu plus privilégiés ?
En tout cas, on n'a pas de PDG d'entreprise, si c'est ça la question. Donc, on n'en a pas. Donc...
C'est remarquable, en tout cas, pour un parti qui donc défend, en tout cas dans ce qu'il présente, principalement la classe ouvrière, les travailleurs, l'idée de dire qu'il y a une source de revenus qui vient de vos membres.
Vous comprenez ce que je veux dire ?
Oui, mais je pense que-
Il existe un patrimoine assez important chez vos membres que pour le donner au parti.
Non, je pense qu'il y a vingt-cinq mille membres du parti qui donnent une contribution chaque fois qui correspond à ce qu'ils savent et ce qu'ils veulent contribuer.
Ils sont nombreux d'un côté. Et d'autre part, oui, il y a des gens qui décident de contribuer au PTB, avec vingt euros, cinquante euros ou cent euros par mois.
Ça fait partie d'un engagement qu'ils ont. Et je pense que dans l'histoire, le mouvement ouvrier s'est construit aussi d'un point de vue financier par le soutien de ses membres.
Si on n'aurait pas eu de soutien financier du mouvement syndical, il y aurait pas eu de Maison du Peuple, il y aurait pas eu de bâtiments syndicaux, il y aurait pas eu tout ça.
Moi, je trouve que c'est une fierté de pouvoir dire que ce qui a été construit, ce qui a été développé, les infrastructures qui ont été portées l'ont été par le collectif.
C'est d'ailleurs une marque, et c'est ce que disent d'ailleurs les experts en financement de parti, c'est une marque d'implication des membres dans l'organisation.
Si vous avez un parti qui vit uniquement des dotations publiques et qui ne doit rien à ses membres, il n'a pas à se justifier.
C'est ce que d'ailleurs, on voit dans les partis libéraux où, bon, c'est des partis où il y a des carrières individuelles qui se font et où finalement, les membres sont parmi les plus maltraités de tous les partis.
C'est, ils sont très très peu consultés. On le voit d'ailleurs dans la formation des listes. Donc, c'est le président du parti qui décide plus ou moins de la composition des listes.
C'est quelque chose qui est inconcevable dans un parti comme le PTB. C'est quelque chose qui se fait à travers l'implication de ses membres.
On reviendra là-dessus peut-être dans un instant. Pour revenir donc une dernière fois sur les dépenses sur Facebook, est-ce que vous pensez que vous allez continuer si, à l'avenir, vous êtes amené à monter au pouvoir ?
Est-ce que vous allez continuer la propagande, les publicités sur Facebook ?
Je n'en sais rien. Je pense que ça dépend. D'abord, il faudra voir si Facebook existe encore. C'est un modèle qui peut changer.
Et on espère que-
Les réseaux sociaux de manière générale, en tout cas.
Oui, dans les réseaux sociaux. Mais il y a des réseaux sociaux où il n'y a pas de financement, il n'y a pas de possibilité de sponsoring.
Ouais, TikTok, c'est pas le sponsoring, c'est autre chose. Vous avez d'autres moyens de communiquer que Facebook.
Donc oui, j'espère qu'un jour, on va pouvoir communiquer autrement. Mais je vous ai expliqué le contexte dans lequel on le fait.
Mais, le par-
Il n'y a pas de principe. On le ferait ou qu'on le ferait pas.
Même si on est actif au gouvernement, c'est pas une raison de s'arrêter ?
Non, je pense que ce n'est pas une question. Donc de toute façon, on a toujours dit que si on était au gouvernement, je pense que la discussion de savoir comment, le mouvement social ne s'arrête pas si on est au gouvernement.
J'espère que le mouvement social continuera parce que-
Et les publicités sont le produit du mouvement social, sont nécessaires pour le mouvement social ?
Je pense que c'est une manière de communiquer directement vis-à-vis des gens. Quand vous avez une presse, et là, je ne parle pas de la presse publique, mais je parle de la presse privée.
La presse privée, aujourd'hui, en Belgique, elle est détenue par certaines forces. Je lisais ce matin...
Parlons-en, parlons-en.
Oui, je lisais ce matin deux ou trois éditos dans lesquels on nous annonce que nous sommes déjà au pouvoir. J'ai téléphoné rapidement à mon président pour savoir s'il était devenu,
ministre président wallon ou bruxellois.
Il m'a confirmé qu'il ne l'était pas. Donc, oui, ça montre déjà, disons, une certaine orientation de ce qu'on peut appeler, voilà, un certain establishment qui existe au niveau politique.
Mais ce n'est pas par hasard si, dans certaines, en tout cas, directions de médias, il y a des intérêts privés.
Et ces intérêts privés ont une certaine vision du monde qui est plutôt statu quo de la situation actuelle. C'est pas des anticapitalistes, hein, je veux dire...
C'est sûr.
Voilà. Donc quand vous avez dans vos actionnaires,
je sais pas, une firme comme Besix, hein, pour prendre cet exemple-là, hein, qui est une firme immobilière qui a des intérêts ici à Bruxelles et ailleurs dans le pays pour construire
des grands projets immobiliers, c'est clair que vous aimez pas trop quand vous avez un parti qui met en cause
les projets immobiliers.
Ça me paraît évident. Je veux dire, c'est de bonne guerre.
C'est un exemple que vous prenez au hasard ou ?
Non, non, je prends cet exemple au hasard. Il peut y avoir plein d'autres exemples qui vous montrent ça. On peut aller voir à l'étranger et on verra la même chose.
Donc, je veux dire, on est dans un système où il y a une super structure qui existe et qui oriente les décisions dans un certain sens.
Au niveau économique, je pense que c'est évident que pas une seule décision importante aujourd'hui en Belgique n'est prise sans un accord minimum d'un certain nombre d'acteurs financiers et économiques.
Il suffit de voir toute la saga autour de l'énergie. Hein. Donc, on a quatre ministres de l'énergie, mais celui qui décide réellement la politique énergétique aujourd'hui en Belgique, c'est le conseil d'administration d'Engie.
J'allais dire, c'est Georges-Louis Bouchez.
Non, non, pas du tout. Pas du tout. Je dirais que dans ce cas-ci, Georges-Louis Bouchez est le porte-valise du conseil d'administration d'Engie.
D'accord.
Je pense que c'est évident quand on regarde la composition des cabinets des ministres de l'énergie des dix dernières années, vous verrez qu'il y a des anciens d'Electrabel à chaque bureau.
C'est incroyable. Je veux dire, c'est tellement évident qu'aujourd'hui, la politique énergétique, on décide en 2003 d'une sortie du nucléaire, on ne fait rien pour faire cette sortie, rien.
Il n'y a pas de vision politique planifiée sur comment on va développer quelque chose d'aussi essentiel que l'énergie.
Et puis on s'aperçoit : Ah tiens, on risque d'avoir un problème d'énergie. Ah ! On va demander à Engie qui dit : Oui, oui, on va le faire, mais alors à nos conditions.
Et voilà, on fait une négociation totalement non transparente. Il y a rien qui se déroule dans le public. Et puis on arrive avec un accord dans lequel, finalement, on va devoir payer pour Engie.
Voilà, Engie va payer une somme et puis pourra se débarrasser de ses déchets nucléaires qui, je vous le rappelle, ont une durée de vie, les déchets nucléaires, de quelques centaines de milliers d'années.
Alors, on va peut-être pas embrayer sur le sujet du nucléaire aujourd'hui, mais je vais revenir sur ce que vous avez dit sur le journalisme, les journalistes, la presse en Belgique.
Donc, si on revient aux origines du parti, il y avait cette histoire avec l'Ordre des médecins qui sanctionnait violemment le...
Alors, rappelez-moi le nom de ce...
Médecine pour le peuple.
Médecine pour le peuple, exactement, voilà. L'Ordre des médecins sanctionnait Médecine pour le peuple pour concurrence déloyale parce qu'ils pratiquaient un tarif fortement réduit.
La justice avait condamné Médecine pour le peuple et le parti, le PTB, avait estimé à l'époque qu'il s'agissait là d'une justice de classe.
Est-ce que vous portez un regard similaire, pour faire un parallèle, sur l'état de la presse aujourd'hui avec une presse qui serait votre adversaire idéologique qui incarnerait l'establishment libéral ?
Comment est-ce que vous vous positionnez par rapport à la presse ?
Non, je pense que c'est plus complexe que ça. Je pense qu'il faut analyser chaque élément de la société de manière précise.
Parce que certains pourraient dire que tous les journalistes sont de droite, tous les journalistes incarnent-
Non, non, non, non, absolument pas. C'est pas notre propos, ce n'est pas du tout notre propos. On examine la structuration de la société, les structures.
On ne parle pas de personnes, on parle de structuration.
Quand vous prenez l'exemple de l'Ordre des médecins, je trouve que c'est un très bon exemple parce que l'Ordre des médecins était à l'époque un ordre corporatiste qui protégeait une médecine libérale.
Une médecine qui avantageait la médecine pour les plus aisés, qui développait un système de prestations, et on peut dire qu'encore aujourd'hui, la médecine en Belgique, au niveau de sa prestation, est une médecine libérale.
Elle n'est pas une médecine comme on l'a connue dans certains pays, d'autres pays en Europe, qui était plus sociale comme on a connu par exemple en Grande-Bretagne après la guerre.
Quand on a été confronté au fait que nous avons
eu des médecins qui sont sortis de l'université et qui se sont dit : Nous allons
être au service de la population et que nous allons pratiquer un tarif gratuit, parce que c'était le tarif remboursé par la mutuelle et qu'on ne demandait pas un complément.
Oui, on a été poursuivi par l'Ordre des médecins et c'est d'abord la justice de l'Ordre des médecins, puisque dans la loi, on laissait à l'Ordre des médecins un pouvoir quasiment judiciaire sur l'exercice de la médecine.
Et c'est ça qu'on a contesté.
Elle était juge et partie.
Elle était juge et partie et nous l'avons contesté. Et ce combat a duré quasiment quarante ans. Et aujourd'hui, en fait, nous avons obtenu gain de cause.
C'est-à-dire que l'Ordre des médecins a changé et n'est plus cet organe complètement réactionnaire qu'il était et a permis le développement, par exemple, de centaines de maisons médicales en Belgique.
Il y a aujourd'hui des centaines de milliers de patients qui sont dans des centres médicaux, pas du PTB, plein d'autres, et qui profitent d'une médecine
au forfait, c'est-à-dire que quand ils vont chez le médecin, ils ne doivent pas payer, ils n'ont rien.
Et donc, dans le journalisme, je pense que là, c'est autre chose.
Vous ne pensez pas que les médias belges sont, comme vous disiez, des organes réactionnaires comme l'Ordre des médecins ?
Non, je pense que c'est plus compliqué. Il faut d'abord analyser la structure et analyser les gens qui travaillent dans cette structure.
Donc oui, il y a un certain nombre d'organes de presse qui sont dans les mains d'actionnaires privés, aisés. Donc ceux qui disent qu'ils n'interviennent pas, c'est de la foutaise.
Ils interviennent rien que par la structure du business. Parce que vous avez des publicités, parce que vous êtes contraints à un certain nombre de choses.
Vous devez dire des choses qui vont plaire à vos publicitaires, sinon on vous enlève votre publicité. Donc, on connaît les cas
à l'étranger, mais en fait aussi en Belgique, de publicités, enfin de gens qui tiennent au niveau publicitaire un certain nombre de choses qui font qu'on n'attaque pas trop.
Et quand ça devient un peu trop chaud, on n'attaque pas trop certains grands groupes privés qui fournissent de la publicité.
En principe, la presse est indépendante et ne doit pas s'associer de qui elle va attaquer. En principe, les journalistes, idéalement, sont en mesure de faire les articles qu'ils souhaitent écrire.
Absolument. Et donc, il y a des journalistes qui le font et il y a des journalistes qui se battent pour leur indépendance.
Mais ils se battent pour leur indépendance parce qu'ils sont soumis à des pressions. Donc, il y a des journalistes, dire que tous les journalistes dans toutes les rédactions font ce qu'ils veulent.
Non, mais non.
Et...
Déjà, tous les journalistes sont engagés parce qu'ils écrivent, parce qu'ils ont un certain penchant, parce qu'ils ont une subjectivité qui peut-être plaît à la personne qui va les engager.
Enfin, je veux dire, on n'atterrit pas dans une rédaction si on a les idées contraires à celui qui possède la rédaction.
Oui, mais l'évolution de beaucoup de journalistes, je pense, c'est que des journalistes sont engagés, peuvent être engagés politiquement de différentes sortes, mais peuvent être indépendants dans leur manière de mener le journalisme.
J'en ai rencontré beaucoup qui sont dans une logique d'investissement, de chercher la vérité dans les faits. Donc tout ça, je pense que si vous prenez beaucoup de journalistes, c'est ça qu'ils font dans leur métier.
Par contre, la structuration de la presse,
je pense comme beaucoup d'autres structures aujourd'hui en Belgique, en Europe et dans le système capitaliste dans lequel on est, on peut l'interroger parce qu'il y a des liens avec des forces économiques.
C'est tout ce que je dis. Je veux dire, quand vous avez des gens dont l'intérêt est que le statu quo économique reste, oui, logiquement, si toute leur rédaction est contre eux, ils auront un problème.
On l'a vu quand Bolloré a repris certaines rédactions. Oui, il a mis dehors les journalistes et ça a duré, oui, il y a eu des grèves, etc.
Mais une fois que je suis propriétaire, c'est à moi. Vous dites : Vous faites ce que moi, j'ai décidé de faire.
Alors, certains de ces patrons de presse sont un plus, on va dire, donnent un peu plus de marge, ne sont pas comme Bolloré, heureusement, parce que sinon, on serait,
on serait dans une autre situation.
Donc, il y a quand même encore une certaine marge démocratique qui est donnée, mais cette marge, elle est plus ou moins limitée.
Donc ça, je pense que ça, c'est vrai.
Donc on peut difficilement être communiste, par exemple, au JT de TF1 ou à la rédaction de La Libre Belgique, par exemple ?
Je pense que c'est assez évident, oui. Je pense que c'est assez évident. Après, ça, c'est notre expérience. On a déjà été très bien reçus par des journalistes de différents médias.
Bien recevoir et puis avoir une ligne éditoriale, c'est deux choses différentes.
Voilà, voilà, voilà, c'est ça, exactement.
Bien voilà, donc ça, c'était pour la parenthèse sur le journalisme. On parlait des évolutions récentes. Je vais me pencher l'espace d'un instant sur les statuts du parti dans lequel il est fait mention
des notions de propagandisme actif et aussi d'un programme de formation des militants.
Alors, je vous pose la question, est-ce que le programme, ce programme de formation aborde la question de la communication et donc de la propagande ?
Et en quoi est-ce que ça consiste exactement ? Parce que tout ça est très opaque.
Non, je pense pas que c'est très opaque. On a des publications larges dans lesquelles on explique un peu ce qu'on défend.
On publie d'ailleurs régulièrement des livres dont on présente. Récemment, nous avons présenté le livre de Peter Mertens, secrétaire général, Mutinerie,
donc qui est un essai sur la situation mondiale et donc dans lequel on essaie d'avancer notre vision sur le monde.
Donc, je pense que comme parti, on est particulièrement attentif à avancer non seulement, on va dire, l'intervention brève, dont on parlait dans les brèves minutes qu'on a dans la presse traditionnelle, à des formats plus longs.
Donc, on a investi, maintenant, nous avons pris l'initiative avec
d'avoir une chaîne YouTube Factoh. On a pris l'initiative d'avoir effectivement des endroits où on peut discuter plus largement et plus profondément de certains points du programme du parti.
Et c'est clair que ça fait partie de notre manière de faire, d'avoir des membres qui sont acteurs du changement, qu'ils connaissent les tenants et les aboutissants de ce parti.
Je pense que c'est important de développer l'aspect politique, idéologique, organisationnel d'un parti et que les membres s'en emparent et que ce ne soit pas limité à quelques dizaines de personnes.
On a une structuration, on a une colonne vertébrale. Si on a une vision fondamentalement marxiste de la société,
oui, c'est quand même très utile que nos membres acquièrent ce que ça veut dire le marxisme d'un point de vue économique, d'un point de vue politique
et que à partir de cette grille d'analyse, ils peuvent appréhender un certain nombre de choses de la vie quotidienne
et de la vie politique.
Ça, je pense que c'est quand même un élément important que des gens qui peuvent maîtriser les enjeux politiques, on va avoir un parti beaucoup plus vivant.
Ça, c'est le but d'une des formations du PTB, c'est de pouvoir avoir une vision sur comment fonctionne le système économique, comment fonctionne le système politique, quelle est la...
tous les éléments qu'on vient de discuter sur la superstructure dans laquelle on se retrouve, les liens entre ça. On a une vision là-dessus et on la défend.
Et je pense que c'est important quand on veut s'émanciper d'un système comme le système capitaliste, d'en connaître les rouages.
Et donc une formation, voilà,
j'allais dire intensive, mais une formation importante des membres du PTB, mais y compris donc sur l'aspect de la communication, puisque si je comprends bien, il y a le souhait de la part du PTB que ses membres soient aussi ses communicants.
Bien sûr, je pense que vous devez communiquer ce que vous faites. Et encore une fois, je pense qu'il y a deux modèles. Il y a un modèle
traditionnel, électoral, dans lequel il y a quelques personnes qui déterminent la ligne du parti et qui la communiquent.
Et puis, il y a un modèle de travail sur le terrain où
si vous voulez rencontrer des milliers et des milliers de gens de manière permanente, vous devez avoir des personnes qui aident sur le terrain et qui sont capables de relayer, d'avancer les éléments
du programme du parti et d'écouter aussi, parce que c'est dans les deux sens, d'écouter ce qui se passe
au niveau de la population.
Quand on décide, par exemple, dans une campagne électorale comme on l'a maintenant, de commencer la campagne électorale déjà au mois de septembre par une enquête,
ce qu'on a appelé la grande enquête, où nous avons interrogé plus de cent mille personnes sur
quelles sont leurs attentes d'un programme électoral, quelles sont leurs visions, qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent mettre à l'agenda politique des revendications que le PTB avance.
C'est à la fois, on pourrait dire, de la communication, mais c'est aussi un exercice de démocratie directe dans lequel on demande aux gens : tiens, c'est quoi les choses sur lesquelles on va se battre ?
Et en fonction de ça, on a défini aussi, on a orienté nos priorités pour la campagne électorale qui a lieu maintenant.
Donc, on l'a expliqué ensemble, le parti a évolué ces dernières décennies. Il y a plus personne de la vieille garde, concrètement, à la tête du parti.
Culturellement et au niveau de la direction, ça reste, entre guillemets, dominé. Enfin, il y a une présence très importante de l'aile flamande du parti.
Toutes les, voilà, les expériences, les premières fois que le PTB monte dans une coalition au niveau communal, la première fois qu'on fait des publicités sur Facebook, etc.
C'est plutôt du côté flamand. Et pourtant, l'écrasante majorité de vos électeurs sont plutôt ou seront bientôt plutôt du côté francophone.
C'est, je trouve ça très intéressant, en fait, le fait qu'il y ait une présence très importante de l'aile flamande du parti à la tête, dans le Conseil national, alors que la plupart des électeurs sont du côté francophone.
Deux remarques par rapport à ce que vous avez dit. D'une part, nous sommes dans un pays où il y a plus de soixante pour cent des gens qui sont néerlandophones.
Donc ça, c'est une première chose. Donc c'est logique qu'il y ait une majorité de gens dans un parti unitaire qui sont néerlandophones.
Il se fait que le parti est organisationnellement aussi important en Flandre qu'en Wallonie et à Bruxelles. Je dirais qu'on est plus ou moins dans les mêmes rapports soixante/quarante que de la population.
Donc ça, c'est important au niveau de l'organisation. Et deuxièmement, au niveau des électeurs, je pense que les prochaines élections montreront qu'il y a un nombre très très important d'électeurs néerlandophones.
Vous savez que si vous faites dix pour cent des voix en Flandre, mécaniquement, vous en avez presque autant que si vous en faisiez quinze en Wallonie.
Donc, on verra au soir du neuf juin, mais je pense qu'on sera dans un rapport assez égal entre les deux. Donc ça, c'est un élément peut-être important dans l'évolution du parti.
D'autre part, le parti, oui, il a commencé, il a eu sa genèse-
Ses racines, oui.
Ses racines-
Walen buiten, tout ça, le...
En Flandre. Et il s'est construit, et c'est quand même assez paradoxal. Et c'est ça qui montre presque la beauté de la politique.
C'est qu'on voit qu'un mouvement qui est porté par des étudiants qui, effectivement, au départ, s'en prennent à une certaine discrimination, à un certain chauvinisme qu'ils voient de la part des francophones.
Des Flamands, oui.
Voilà, évolue
et passe du Wallen Burton à Bourgeois Burton,
parce que c'est ça qui a évolué dans cette, dans ce parti et qui aboutisse à la conclusion qu'ils ne doivent pas s'orienter contre les Flamands, mais contre une certaine bourgeoisie, qu'elle soit flamande ou francophone.
Et donc, ça amène à un développement d'abord en Flandre et puis en Wallonie. Mais aujourd'hui, à la tête du parti, il y a des francophones, des néerlandophones.
Il y a des... Moi, je suis francophone à l'origine, donc voilà, je suis, je vais dire, je suis l'incarnation de la partie francophone, si vous voulez le dire comme ça.
Vous êtes un vrai, un vrai Belge. Vous avez appris le néerlandais, vous êtes actif dans un parti unitaire. C'est ça que...
Oui, je crois que... Je pense que ça, c'est la force du PTB, c'est qu'on arrive à faire rencontrer des gens qui se rencontreraient pas normalement.
C'est quand même assez fou. On est dans le seul pays fédéral où il n'y a pas de partis nationaux, sauf le PTB. Et donc-
Et la N-VA, maintenant, qui est présente au sein du pays.
Oui, enfin, la N-VA, elle a d'autres politiques.
C'est une boutade.
Oui, bien sûr, j'ai bien compris.
Mais magnifique transition que vous m'offrez vis-à-vis des questions marxistes. Question pour vous, histoire de peut-être vous piéger un petit peu.
Est-ce que vous connaissez le pourcentage des ouvriers dans la population belge ?
Ça dépend comment on les définit. Donc, ça dépend comment vous définissez les ouvriers. Donc, soit vous les définissez avec le statut ouvrier, soit vous les définissez comme des travailleurs ayant un diplôme-
Ou sans diplôme, du coup.
Sans diplôme ou avec un diplôme du secondaire. Donc, si vous prenez les gens avec un diplôme du secondaire ou moins que le secondaire, dans la classe travailleuse, vous serez à soixante pour cent.
Donc, oui, si vous prenez cette définition-là, si vous prenez les travailleurs de l'industrie, vous serez à vingt, vingt à vingt-cinq pour cent.
Donc moi, par exemple, je n'ai pas de diplôme supérieur. Je me suis arrêté au secondaire.
Ouais.
Je suis parfaitement bourgeois.
Oui, ça, c'est possible par rapport à votre fonction sociale. Ça, j'en sais rien, je vous connais pas.
Oui.
Je veux dire, ça dépend la situation dans laquelle vous êtes.
Voilà, voilà. C'est ça le vrai critère, finalement, la situation.
Oui, mais au niveau des revenus, vous avez des gens qui ont des revenus... Si vous regardez, c'est pas seulement le revenu qui détermine votre position sociale, c'est aussi : est-ce que vous avez un patron ?
Mm-hmm.
Hein ? Est-ce que vous êtes dans un travail manuel ou intellectuel ?
Oui.
Donc tout ça, ça joue sur-
Les critères, oui.
Ça, ça joue sur la fonction que vous avez. Je dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui, quand vous regardez, si vous prenez le critère des gens
qui ont un diplôme de secondaire ou inférieur, il y a soixante pour cent des gens qui sont salariés en Belgique qui sont dans cette situation-là.
Or, si vous regardez, par exemple, la représentation de cette couche importante, majoritaire parmi les salariés, dans le Parlement, il y en a cinq sur cent cinquante.
Cinq sur cent cinquante. Et ils sont tous au PTB. Sauf un.
Comme je vous le challengeais il y a un instant, soixante pour cent sur base juste de la question du diplôme, ça permet de faire gonfler un peu le chiffre.
Et donc, je suis dans ces soixante pour cent.
Ouais.
Je ne suis pas un prolétaire.
Non, mais il y a des gens qui sont dans une situation, qui ont fait un diplôme universitaire et qui se retrouvent dans une situation où ils travaillent d'un point de vue manuel.
Donc, ça dépend. Non, non, mais bien sûr, vous pouvez prendre le critère de l'industrie et regarder tous ceux qui travaillent dans l'industrie, qui sont salariés, vous allez être autour de vingt-cinq pour cent.
Voilà, ouais.
Hein, donc oui, ça dépend. Mais il y a de nombreuses caissières, aides-soignantes, etc.
Livreurs Uber Eats.
Livreurs ou, qui sont dans les services et qui ne sont pas considérés comme ouvriers alors qu'ils le sont. Donc, il faut faire attention
à ces distinctions qui ont amené, moi, je trouve, voilà, ça, c'est notre vision des classes, qui ont amené un peu à l'idée qu'il y aurait, en gros,
les riches, une classe moyenne et les exclus.
Ça, c'est la vision qui est dominante, même dans une certaine gauche traditionnelle.
Oui, et puis il y a nonante pour cent de la population qui s'identifie comme étant dans la classe moyenne.
Oui, mais ça ne correspond pas à des rapports sociaux concrets. Les rapports sociaux concrets que vous avez, c'est : est-ce que vous êtes salarié ?
Est-ce que vous dépendez d'un patron ? Et dans ce rapport concret que vous avez avec ce patron, est-ce que vous êtes dans une situation où, par votre diplôme, par une qualification importante, vous pouvez, de manière aisée, changer de travail ?
Ou est-ce que parce que vous venez d'être sans qualification, vous êtes dans un rapport beaucoup plus difficile par rapport à votre emploi ?
Parce que dès que vous le perdez, vous risquez d'être au chômage pour une très longue durée. Ça, c'est un peu le dilemme que beaucoup de travailleurs ont aujourd'hui en Belgique.
Et donc oui, c'est un élément important. Et puis, est-ce que vous êtes exploité par votre patron ? Comment il le fait ?
C'est évident que si vous êtes en usine ou vous êtes livreur Uber Eats, c'est autre chose que si vous travaillez à l'université.
Voilà. Vous pointiez du doigt, donc, il y a un instant, le décalage entre les pourcentages. Bon, difficile de se mettre d'accord sur les chiffres.
Est-ce que c'est soixante pour cent ? Est-ce que c'est vingt-cinq pour cent ? Mais vous pointiez du doigt, en tout cas, le décalage entre
l'importance de la classe ouvrière à l'échelle du pays et sa représentation, par exemple, à la Chambre des représentants.
Je vais simplement vous dire que la grande majorité des cadres du PTB ont fait des études supérieures. Vous, par exemple, vous êtes diplômé de Polytech.
Votre famille a une histoire au sein du parti. Est-ce que ce n'est pas contradictoire à ce moment-là, vu le constat, que ce parti-là, cet appareil-là, se revendique comme étant le parti des travailleurs ?
Je pense que c'est une question qu'on s'est posée à notre dernier congrès et que c'est un des défis que nous avons devant nous.
C'est-à-dire qu'effectivement, on veut être un parti qui, dans sa structure et dans son évolution, soit un parti qui soit porté plus par des travailleurs que par des gens qui sont issus des classes intellectuelles.
Ça, c'est évident. Ça, c'est le travail que nous sommes en train de faire et c'est un défi que nous avons comme parti du travail.
Oui, on l'a posé. Je crois qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de partis qui ont osé poser ce problème.
Je pense que la grande différence, c'est que, un, d'abord, nous posons cette question comme une question stratégique pour nous,
de la sous-représentation dans des fonctions dirigeantes et dans des fonctions représentatives des travailleurs et des travailleurs non qualifiés en particulier.
Donc ça, c'est une chose qu'on est en train de changer. Et deuxièmement, et donc on le pose comme un problème, et deuxièmement, on le change et on le change concrètement.
Et c'est un changement et c'est évident que dans une société où on écrase les travailleurs, où on leur empêche d'accéder aux connaissances, la reproduction culturelle et la reproduction sociale, elle se fait.
Je pense que c'est évident. Mais ça n'empêche pas qu'il peut y avoir des intellectuels qui se mettent au service des travailleurs.
Et ça, c'est aussi ce que font les intellectuels dans le PTB.
Mais donc, il y a quand même chez vous une autocritique, on peut vous reconnaître vis-à-vis de ce décalage entre le...
Absolument, mais je constate que dans d'autres partis de gauche, le problème n'est même pas posé et qu'il y a un recul terrible par rapport à ça.
Donc, quand vous regardez, par exemple, le Parti socialiste, il n'y a plus aucun ouvrier dans leur... Il n'y a aucun ouvrier député, aucun ouvrier dans leur fonction dirigeante.
Personne. Donc là, on est dans une évolution qui, à mon avis, est négative et qu'on doit consciemment aller dans l'autre sens.
Et je pense que c'est un débat qui doit traverser toutes les organisations sociales en Belgique. Il faut pouvoir que les travailleurs soient représentés par des travailleurs, oui.
Vous présentiez un peu plus tôt dans cet entretien le PTB comme étant le parti où se rencontrent les gens qui ne se seraient jamais rencontrés autrement.
Donc ici, on parle alors des classes populaires, les prolétaires et ce qu'on va appeler les intellectuels ou les personnes plus privilégiées, la bourgeoisie.
Est-ce que c'est ça qui représente un défi ? Est-ce qu'il y a une difficulté à se faire rencontrer ces deux sphères-là ?
Dans la société, certainement.
Dans le parti.
Mais donc le parti n'est pas indépendant de la société. Le parti est un reflet qu'on peut changer de manière consciente.
C'est la fonction d'une organisation de changer sa manière d'envisager les choses. Mais comme individu dans une société capitaliste, y compris en étant marxiste, vous êtes le produit de cette société aussi.
Vous êtes pétri de contradictions, donc vous êtes confronté à cette société. Donc, qu'on soit influencé par des préjugés élitistes, par des préjugés de classe, y compris quand on se définit comme marxiste, ça me paraît évident.
Donc, votre organisation, vous essayez de la rencontrer et de regarder quels sont les mécanismes qui, dans la société, font qu'on exclut des gens des fonctions dirigeantes.
Si, par exemple, je vais vous donner un exemple qui peut-être va vous paraître banal, mais si la culture de l'écrit est une culture qui est portée par surtout les intellectuels, la culture de l'oral est plus
quelque chose qui est porté dans le milieu populaire.
Si la plupart de votre communication se fait de manière écrite et si votre manière de faire, d'aborder les choses se fait de manière écrite,
vous handicapez d'une manière, que vous le veuillez ou non, l'accès à la connaissance d'une série de gens issus des classes populaires et vous avantagez, entre guillemets, les gens qui ont un background intellectuel.
Donc, vous devez consciemment prendre en main cette question et voir comment vous résolvez ce problème. Et comme ça, je peux vous en citer des dizaines d'exemples de mécanismes concrets qui font qu'aujourd'hui,
dans des fonctions, y compris dans des organisations de gauche, il y a une difficulté pour des travailleurs pour accéder.
Aujourd'hui, on a dans notre direction des gens comme Nadia Moscufo, qui est une ancienne caissière d'Aldi et qui apporte ce combat au sein même de la direction du PTB.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez pouvoir mettre en place alors pour résoudre ce décalage entre ce que vous aimeriez atteindre en termes de pourcentage de prolétaires dans le parti, dans le PTB, et la réalité actuelle ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez pouvoir mettre en place ?
Je pense que surtout, il faut pouvoir donner... D'abord, je pense que c'est comme pour beaucoup de choses, il faut d'abord problématiser la question.
La première chose, reconnaître le problème.
Reconnaître le problème.
Ça, c'est fait. C'est dans votre dernier congrès.
C'est dans notre dernier congrès, mais je pense que reconnaître un problème, ça prend du temps. Et comme je dis, par exemple, le fait qu'il y a des mécanismes concrets qui se font.
Deuxièmement, nous avons avancé aussi le fait qu'on doit avoir des espaces où les travailleurs s'expriment de manière majoritaire, c'est-à-dire qu'ils puissent exprimer
entre eux la manière dont ils voient les choses et que la culture intellectuelle, elles dominent un certain nombre, peuvent dominer un certain nombre de manières de faire et que donc, on doit combattre ça.
Ça fait partie des formations, de la priorité qu'on va donner aux formations vis-à-vis des travailleurs. Ça va être aussi une question de donner une discrimination positive pour des fonctions dans le parti.
Donc tout ça, c'est des choses très concrètes. C'est-à-dire, naturellement, qui sait faire un communiqué de presse, qui sait faire une vidéo, qui sait faire ceci ou cela.
Souvent, ça va être des gens qui seront diplômés, qui vont dire : Ah oui, mais moi, je sais le faire. Si vous n'apprenez pas et si vous ne développez pas des qualifications sur ce thème-là pour des personnes travailleuses.
Des camarades.
Des camarades, travailleurs et travailleuses.
J'ai entendu.
Oui, tout à fait. J'assume. Oui, ça, c'est des choses qu'on fait. C'est des choses qu'on met en place et qu'on va développer.
Et c'est effectivement un changement de culture politique dans le parti.
Oui. Et donc c'est une transition qui n'est pas encore faite, mais que vous allez entamer.
Qu'on est en train de faire et qui ça demande, je pense que ça demande, comme toute cette transition assez fondamentale, il faut donner le temps au temps.
Bien sûr. Vous avez organisé, on en parlait il y a un instant, un congrès en 2022 qui est censé logiquement baliser la direction du parti pour les cinq années qui suivent.
Il y a très peu de communication autour de ce parti. Là, vous en parlez, vous évoquez les problématiques qui ont été posées.
Mais on ne peut pas vraiment accéder aux documents, aux conclusions de ce congrès, à moins d'être membre. Il y a apparemment plusieurs versions du document qui circulent, qui existent, qui font plusieurs tailles différentes.
Écoutez, on a des sources là-dessus, mais la notion de confidentialité revient à plusieurs reprises aussi dans les statuts du parti.
C'est une exigence vis-à-vis des membres qui doivent comprendre le besoin de confidentialité.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a ce goût de discrétion, de l'opacité et de la confidentialité, au jusqu'au point de le mettre dans les statuts du parti ?
D'abord, il y a un document du Congrès que vous pouvez acheter en ligne, ptbshop.be. Vous pouvez l'acheter en ligne.
L'acheter, mais ok, il est pas en PDF ?
Non, on n'est pas en PDF, mais vous pouvez... Il est disponible et il y a un seul document officiel qui a été voté par les délégués au Congrès.
Il y en avait plus de neuf cent. Donc, voilà. Donc, ce document, il est là, il est balisé, il est écrit, il est définitif, enfin, tout ce qu'on veut.
Je pense que nous, on part d'une idée de,
d'une démocratie interne
où en gros, on essaye que toutes les opinions dans le parti s'expriment en toute liberté, mais avec l'idée que tout ce qu'on a dit, on n'est pas obligé de le raconter sur la place publique parce que,
il se peut que voilà, il y a des choses qu'on a envie, on lave son linge sale en famille, donc on dit les choses entre nous.
On se dit, voilà, sur quoi on est d'accord et sur quoi on n'est pas d'accord. Et après, on sort avec un point de vue sur lequel on a fait un consensus, on a fait une unité après un débat démocratique large.
Notre congrès, c'est un an de débats dans le parti où tout le monde a pu dire voilà, ce qui n'allait pas, ce qui allait bien, ce qu'il fallait changer dans le parti.
Et donc, par exemple, la discussion qu'on vient d'avoir sur la place des ouvriers, c'est une discussion qui confronte des pratiques différentes, qui confronte des manières de voir différentes dans le parti.
Et puis, on le conclut à travers
un congrès. Moi, je constate que dans d'autres partis, la liberté de s'exprimer vers l'extérieur aboutit toujours à la liberté de celui qui a la plus grande gueule ou de celui qui est capable de communiquer vers les médias,
par rapport à ses opinions.
On pourrait parler de capital culturel. Quelqu'un qui a un accès aux médias ou qui a un accès à la voie publique aura plus d'écho dans la presse que quelqu'un qui l'a moins.
La confidentialité, ça résout ce problème-là ? Je suis pas sûr de vous suivre.
La confidentialité fait en sorte que si vous avez des discussions et que vous n'êtes pas d'accord entre vous, vous exprimez vos désaccords dans le parti,
dans une structure dans laquelle vous êtes entre personnes qui partagez la même, le même idéal et dans laquelle vous, entre guillemets, vous tranchez vos contradictions.
Il y a débat au sein du parti, mais quel rapport avec l'accès aux médias ? Je ne suis pas sûr de vous suivre.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que dans d'autres partis, les divergences et les confidentialités des débats sont peu présentes.
On les rend ouvertes et souvent, on les rend ouvertes sur la place publique. Je ne veux pas faire le procès d'un autre parti ici, mais si vous prenez...
Vous êtes un peu en train de le faire, mais oui.
Non, non, non, non, mais je prends un exemple que tout le monde connaît...
Défi.
Défi, je veux dire, ça s'appelle régler ses problèmes sur la place publique. Je pense que ce n'est pas, on le voit, ce n'est pas la meilleure chose à faire dans un parti...
C'est pas une bonne stratégie.
C'est pas une bonne stratégie et ça ne permet pas aux gens de la base de s'exprimer. Parce que finalement, qu'est-ce qu'on voit ?
C'est un débat entre deux personnes, deux barons qui ont accès aux médias. Mais les gens qui sont dans ce parti et qui ont un point de vue probablement nuancé sur les contradictions, j'en sais rien, je connais pas ce parti à l'intérieur.
D'accord. Mais est-ce qu'on entend la base du PTB qui a un avis nuancé sur la question ? Non.
Vous savez, il y a plein de journalistes qui les interviewent à chaque événement du PTB.
Il y a eu des reportages dans La Libre, dans Le Vif, dans la...
Puisqu'il y a ce besoin de confidentialité qui est exigé dans les statuts du parti.
Mais parce qu'il y a un certain nombre de choses que nous voulons discuter dans notre parti, entre personnes et entre membres du parti.
Vous comprenez qu'il y a donc d'autres partis qui ont plutôt une culture de la transparence dans leurs documents, dans leurs chiffres, dans leurs congrès, etc.
Parfois disponible en vidéo, enfin, soit. Et vous parlez de quel parti ?
Bah...
Non, non, mais je veux dire de quel parti ? Parce que je voudrais bien savoir en quoi le G onze de monsieur Boucher, le G sept de monsieur Magnette est accessible au public.
Je pense à Ecolo, par exemple.
Oui, mais Ecolo n'ouvre pas son assemblée à la presse. Donc, il y a, il à un moment donné, et je trouve ça normal. Je trouve ça normal comme pratique politique.
Il y a un moment donné où il y a un débat qui se fait en dehors des caméras pour pouvoir avoir un débat contradictoire.
C'est souvent filmé quand même. On retrouve quand même souvent sur les réseaux sociaux des extraits de...
Ça, c'est leur problème. Mais je veux dire, le fait de pouvoir... Justement, je trouve ça très intéressant. Vous filmez un débat.
Qui filme le débat ? Qu'est-ce qu'il veut diffuser vers l'extérieur ? À quel but ? Etc. Pourquoi la personne qui a plus accès qu'un autre ?
Ça me semble normal que dans une organisation humaine, quand vous êtes d'accord sur un certain nombre d'objectifs, vous discutiez librement, loin des caméras et qu'après, vous exprimiez votre opinion.
Ça n'empêche pas toute personne qui rencontre quelqu'un du PTB va vous dire : « Je suis tombé sur l'un et l'autre.
Ils me disent pas exactement la même chose. » Évidemment, chaque être humain est différent. Mais qu'il y a une ligne politique qui est portée par un parti politique, moi, je trouve ça sain.
Je trouve ça, ça fait partie du débat politique d'avoir un collectif qui avance et qui s'exprime. Et je dis simplement que
dans un certain nombre d'autres partis, en ayant une haute culture politique, la réalité, c'est que c'est une fausse démocratie.
Quand on dit : tout est ouvert, c'est souvent les mêmes qu'on entend qui expriment leurs divergences et d'autres, nous, on les entend pas.
Donc nous, on a préféré dire : on n'entend personne. Et il y a un porte-parole, il y a quelqu'un qui exprime à un moment donné le point de vue du parti.
Et le point de vue, par exemple, d'un Raoul Hedebouw ou le point de vue que j'exprime aujourd'hui, c'est pas mon point de vue personnel.
Je suis mandaté pour mon parti, pour défendre la position de mon parti. Je vais pas vous raconter si je vais prendre un verre après cet entretien dans un café, je vous raconterai ma vie, mais je vais pas le faire ici.
C'est pas ma fonction.
Mais en fait, ce qu'il y a, c'est que cette culture de la confidentialité fait qu'il y a forcément, ça laisse place à la spéculation.
On se demande ce qui a lieu derrière ces portes fermées, ce qui est discuté et ça laisse place au fantasme.
Je vais dire, vous auriez, nous avons eu, on a reçu les caméras de la RTBF, un bureau de parti ici, ils ont filmé.
Il y a encore des gens qui font des fantasmes. Je veux dire, il y a des gens qui vont continuer. Vous savez, je crois qu'il y a une mythologie bien ancrée
dans un certain nombre de classes dominantes qui ont l'habitude, eux, de vivre dans le secret,
qui ont l'habitude de régler tous leurs problèmes en coulisses, mais de commencer à fantasmer ou de supposer que
les communistes mangent les enfants.
Donc oui, c'est un vieux mythe qui est véhiculé que les gens auraient un double, alors que ces gens sont constamment en train de faire des choses derrière le dos des gens.
Je trouve ça extraordinaire que j'entends parfois des libéraux nous faire des leçons de démocratie et ils ont négocié avec Engie et trouvent ça tout à fait normal que ça se passe derrière des murs secrets à l'abri de tous.
Très bien. David Pestieau, on va bientôt devoir se quitter. On arrive au bout de cet entretien. Dernière question que je voulais explorer avec vous, c'est la question de l'actualité internationale.
Question très simple que je vais vous poser : est-ce qu'il existe un apartheid en Palestine ? Est-ce qu'un génocide est en cours en Palestine ?
Oui, je pense que... J'ai commencé mon engagement dans les années quatre-vingt en m'engageant à une époque où une grande partie de la jeunesse se mobilisait contre l'apartheid en Afrique du Sud.
Et aujourd'hui, et comme d'ailleurs l'a dit Mandela, nous ne serons jamais libres si nous n'arrivons pas à avoir la libération de la Palestine de l'oppression dans laquelle elle se trouve.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui, il y a un État israélien qui se définit sur l'exclusion de l'autre. Ce n'est pas un État qui accepte et qui donne des droits égaux à tous ses habitants et qui occupe une partie d'autres territoires et qui aujourd'hui
a décidé, visiblement, si on en croit ses ministres, les déclarations propres de ses ministres,
d'écraser les animaux humains qui se trouvent à Gaza.
Ce sont les déclarations du ministre de la Défense au début de la guerre. Et tout le comportement de l'armée et du gouvernement israélien depuis cette annonce a été dans ce sens.
Si vous regardez le déroulement de cette guerre, on a d'abord dégagé, on a prétendu qu'il fallait dégager le nord de Gaza et faire replier les gens vers le sud de Gaza pour les protéger, pour permettre de bombarder les véritables ennemis.
Et puis, arrivé au sud de Gaza, on a dit que ce serait une partie de Gaza. Et maintenant, la menace est portée sur la dernière enclave où s'entassent plus d'un million de personnes.
Et donc oui, il y a quelque chose de dramatique qui se déroule, où d'une part, la population est victime de bombardements, d'autre part, est menacée de famine et où la seule voie de sortie qu'on lui propose est l'exil.
Donc oui, quand la Cour de justice internationale, dans un arrêt exceptionnel, dit qu'il y a des indications qu'il y a un génocide en cours, je pense qu'il faut prendre ça très au sérieux.
Et je suis d'une génération qui a connu aussi le génocide au Rwanda et où je me rappelle que nous étions parfois très seuls quand nous dénoncions, entre le mois d'avril et le mois de juillet, le terrible sort des Tutsis qui se faisaient massacrer. Parce que
le gouvernement en place à l'époque au Rwanda était soutenu par nos gouvernements, la Belgique et la France. Et que ce n'est que quand le génocide a été un fait
et qu'il a été finalement arrêté, qu'on a reconnu qu'il y a eu un génocide, même après quelques mois.
Donc moi, ça ne m'intéresse pas
tellement d'assister de manière désemparée et de constater après les choses. Je pense que la mobilisation qu'on connaît en Belgique, qu'on connaît en Europe et qu'on connaît dans le reste du monde pour arrêter ce génocide
est une mobilisation légitime et importante et historique.
Parce que ce qui se passe là va, à mon avis, influencer beaucoup de choses dans les années à venir. Parce que ce qui se passe là va bien au-delà de la question israélo-palestinienne.
Et qu'est-ce que la Belgique peut faire ? Qu'est-ce que le PTB aimerait pouvoir mettre en place pour aider la situation en Palestine ?
Et est-ce que vous êtes en faveur de sanctions contre l'État d'Israël ?
On a dit depuis le début que nous trouvions anormal que la Belgique continuait à envoyer, à laisser transiter et parfois envoyer des armes en Israël.
Nous l'avons dénoncé concrètement au Parlement avec des révélations. Donc oui, nous sommes pour un embargo militaire par rapport à Israël depuis le départ.
Deuxièmement, nous avons dit qu'il y a un accord de coopération, de partenariat privilégié entre l'Union européenne et Israël.
Donc, ce n'est pas une question de rapport économique, c'est de rapport privilégié au niveau économique, que nous estimions que cet accord de partenariat devait être remis en cause.
Donc, nous estimons qu'il faut passer des paroles aux actes. Au départ, on n'était pas en train de reconnaître qu'il y avait une agression israélienne sur la Palestine.
Aujourd'hui, on l'admet du bout des lèvres avec beaucoup de réticence, mais on ne prend quasiment rien comme sanction et on remarque effectivement
un certain deux poids, deux mesures par rapport à ce qui a été fait dans d'autres conflits, que ce soit par exemple le conflit entre l'invasion illégale de la Russie en Ukraine.
On a eu un paquet de sanctions directement. On a traîné monsieur Poutine devant le Tribunal international. On a tout de suite pris les devants pour faire tout ça.
On ne voit rien de tout ça quand il s'agit d'un allié de l'Occident comme Israël. Et on le voit dans d'autres conflits.
On le voit au Congo avec le Rwanda, on le voit dans plusieurs autres conflits. On voit un deux poids, deux mesures et je pense que l'Europe doit se détacher d'une politique qu'elle mène depuis trop longtemps,
qui est une politique de deux poids, deux mesures qui est très très très très mal perçue par la majorité de la population mondiale.
Et elle doit se ressaisir parce que si elle continue, elle va s'enfermer dans un isolement avec les États-Unis
et elle va se couper du reste du monde qui, je le rappelle, c'est la majorité du peuple, des peuples du monde habitent dans les pays du Sud.
Et donc, pour clarifier explicitement, des sanctions contre l'État d'Israël.
Bien sûr, des sanctions, bien sûr. J'ai essayé d'être précis dans ce que j'ai dit, dans ce que ça voulait dire des sanctions.
Je pense que de toute façon, on doit exercer toutes les possibilités de pression sur le gouvernement israélien.
Il y a la procédure en cours à La Haye. Il y a le fait qu'on devrait, à mon avis, traîner monsieur Netanyahou devant la Cour internationale.
Il y a le fait qu'on devrait rappeler à l'ordre l'ambassade israélienne. Et pour moi, on devrait rappeler l'ambassade belge en Israël.
Ça, c'est mon avis par rapport à tout ce qui s'est passé. Je vois à chaque fois des mécanismes qui font qu'il y a un deux poids, deux mesures.
Il y a eu un bombardement, une attaque récente de l'Iran en réponse à un bombardement israélien sur le consulat iranien en Syrie, ce qui est une nouveauté majeure dans les deux cas.
Donc d'un côté, une attaque contre une ambassade étrangère dans un autre pays par un pays et de l'autre côté, une réponse iranienne.
Je constate qu'on est en train de prendre des sanctions que vis-à-vis d'une seule partie, l'Iran. Donc,
avec une telle politique, on ne doit pas s'étonner que les pays du Sud commencent à se dire : mais pourquoi on devrait prendre l'Europe comme une référence ?
Et ça, je pense que ça doit nous interroger et doit nous amener à développer une politique de solidarité des peuples d'Europe avec ceux des peuples du Sud.
Ça, c'est notre démarche à nous comme PTB, qu'on avance. Par rapport à ça, on développe un mouvement de solidarité pour la paix à Gaza, au Congo, en Ukraine.
Donc ça, on pense que c'est un grand combat de ce début du vingt-et-unième siècle, le combat pour la paix.
Oui. Vous parliez de deux poids, deux mesures. On vous reproche régulièrement d'être un peu trop copain avec la Chine et la Russie.
Est-ce que vous êtes également en faveur de sanctions contre la Russie dans le contexte actuel ?
Nous avons dit que les sanctions qui ont été prises par rapport à la Russie, nous étions pour des sanctions qui visaient les oligarques.
Nous étions pour des sanctions qui visaient les gens autour de monsieur Poutine. Ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'on a fait des sanctions qui ont été tellement larges et tellement
peu ciblées qu'elles sont retombées d'abord sur la population russe, mais surtout, elles sont retombées sur la population occidentale.
Aujourd'hui, le fait que nous n'importons plus du gaz russe n'a eu aucun impact sur l'exportation des gaz russes. Donc, monsieur Poutine continue à vendre son gaz.
Sauf que maintenant, le gaz que nous achetons est un gaz américain qui est deux fois plus cher. Et donc aujourd'hui, notre industrie souffre.
Notre industrie souffre terriblement parce que les prix de l'énergie se sont envolés. Et donc on a, à mon avis, eu un backlash de ces sanctions.
Donc, je trouve que ça a été une politique particulièrement peu...
Ciblée.
Peu ciblée. Et deuxièmement, nous l'avons déjà dit, nous sommes pour un cessez-le-feu après l'invasion de la Russie en Ukraine.
Nous avons dit que nous ne comprenions pas pourquoi il n'y avait pas plus d'initiatives prises. Il n'y en a eu aucune prise depuis la guerre par l'Union européenne pour obtenir un cessez-le-feu.
On s'est simplement aligné sur les Américains dans une politique d'escalade. Et aujourd'hui, l'Europe est enfermée dans une impasse, dans un conflit face à une puissance nucléaire.
Et donc nous, on dit simplement, face à une puissance nucléaire, la seule solution va passer par la négociation. Bien sûr, il faut faire des pressions.
Bien sûr, il faut défendre la souveraineté de l'Ukraine, mais il faudra passer par des négociations et pas par la confrontation telle qu'on est en train de le faire. On va arriver à—
La négociation, ça impliquerait des compromis.
Bien sûr.
Et donc potentiellement, le fait de céder des territoires en faveur de la Russie.
Écoutez, j'ai—
Parce que c'est ça qu'ils exigent.
Mais écoutez, d'abord, tout conflit et toute guerre se termine soit par la destruction d'un des deux adversaires. Je ne souhaite pas que l'Ukraine soit détruite jusqu'à son dernier truc et pas dans l'autre sens non plus.
Vous ne souhaitez pas la destruction du Kremlin ?
Que monsieur Poutine s'en aille. J'espère que les Russes vont s'en occuper. Hein ?
Est-ce qu'ils sont en mesure de le faire ?
Mais j'espère. Nous avons combattu Poutine depuis qu'il a accédé au pouvoir, ce qui n'est pas le cas de monsieur Verhofstadt et de l'élite belge qui a négocié avec monsieur Poutine pendant plus de dix ans.
Donc, je n'ai pas de leçon sur ça. Moi, je suis en contact avec des gens qui se battent en Russie pour la paix et contre monsieur Poutine.
Non, ce qui m'indigne dans cette question, c'est qu'on doit arriver à un accord et on doit se battre pour des négociations de paix.
Je constate que tout au début de la guerre, et ce n'est pas moi qui le dis, c'est le Foreign Affairs, qui vient de sortir un article, je vous invite à le lire.
Qui démontre qu'il y avait pratiquement un accord entre l'Ukraine et la Russie au début de la guerre.
2015 alors ?
Non, non, en 2022, au début de la guerre, le premier, après deux mois—
La guerre a commencé en 2015, monsieur.
Oui oui, mais en 2022, donc la partie où la Russie intervient directement avec des troupes au sol et envahit l'Ukraine.
C'était déjà le cas en 2015.
Avec la Crimée. Mais je veux dire, je parle de l'Ukraine. Oui oui, bien sûr, c'est vrai. Mais je veux dire, à partir de 2022, où il y a une attaque sur Kiev et sur les territoires,
ukrainiens, on va dire continentaux ou pas la Crimée,
on peut dire qu'à partir de ce moment-là et après deux mois, il y a eu des possibilités de négociations qui ont été torpillées, non pas par les Ukrainiens, non pas par les Russes, mais par les Occidentaux.
Et c'est dans le Foreign Affairs. Je vous invite à le lire.
Je mettrai le lien en description.
Oui oui, donc il faut le lire. Et ça montre qu'il y avait des possibilités d'accord à ce moment-là qui respectaient la souveraineté ukrainienne.
Donc, je dis simplement qu'on doit arriver à un accord de paix en Ukraine pour éviter une catastrophe nucléaire et une escalade nucléaire dont c'est l'intérêt de personne.
Et donc, concrètement, l'engagement de la Belgique pour fournir des F16 à l'Ukraine dans les cinq prochaines années, le PTB s'y oppose ?
Bien sûr, on a dit et on a expliqué pourquoi on s'y opposait. Et je pense que—
Est-ce que le PTB au pouvoir serait prêt à revenir sur cet engagement de la Belgique ?
Eh bien sûr.
Rétroactivement ?
Bien sûr, je pense que ça ne fait pas partie d'un processus de paix. Vous savez, il y a d'autres pays en Europe qui ne s'engagent pas dans la guerre, comme la Belgique, l'Autriche, l'Irlande.
La Suisse.
Ce sont des pays... Oui, la Suisse, mais je parle de pays de l'Union européenne. L'Autriche, l'Irlande et d'autres pays n'ont pas un engagement comme ceux des autres pays de l'OTAN.
Donc ça, c'est une première chose. Deuxièmement, la majorité des pays dans le monde plaident pour des négociations. Il y a eu des tentatives de négociations avec l'Union africaine.
Il y a eu des tentatives de négociations avec des pays asiatiques. Il y a eu des tentatives de négociations avec monsieur Lula du Brésil.
Il y a eu même des tentatives du pape. Donc, je constate simplement qu'il y a des forces de paix, il y a des gens qui plaident pour la paix et la négociation, mais qu'on est dans une logique d'escalade.
Et je pense qu'il faut, nous, en tant qu'Européens, pas rentrer dans une logique de suivre la politique américaine, qui est visiblement dans une logique de confrontation avec la Russie, mais d'arriver à une solution négociée.
Et une solution négociée, ce n'est pas dire qu'on se plie devant monsieur Poutine. Pas du tout.
Pas du tout. Une solution négociée, c'est arriver à quelque chose de juste, mais où on arrête le massacre en cours, où il y a des dizaines de milliers de victimes.
Chaque jour de guerre qui passe, ce sont des gens qui meurent et il vaudrait mieux passer des mois à négocier et avoir un cessez-le-feu que de continuer un seul jour de guerre.
Oui. Vous présentez la chose comme étant vraiment un combat entre deux acteurs, l'Occident, les États-Unis et la Russie de Vladimir Poutine de l'autre côté.
Je pense que Vladimir Zelensky lui-même n'est pas dans une situation où il prône la négociation.
Non, il ne prône pas la négociation. Il y a d'autres forces en Ukraine qui sont pour la négociation, comme il y a d'autres forces en Russie qui sont pour la paix.
Je pense qu'on est dans une logique, donc, on le sait assez bien en Belgique, ce n'est pas le Premier ministre qui détermine l'opinion de ces pays-là.
Donc, il y a d'autres forces, et en Russie et en Ukraine,
qui plaident pour la paix aujourd'hui. Et je dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui, on l'a vu, on a des indications assez fortes que les États-Unis ont poussé et continuent à pousser l'Ukraine à un affrontement parce que ça les arrange d'avoir
une guerre de proxy, c'est-à-dire une guerre par rapport à un adversaire stratégique.
Madame Hillary Clinton l'a dit clairement dans un article avant la guerre
: ça nous arrangerait bien qu'on ait un scénario à l'Afghanistan en Ukraine, c'est-à-dire que la Russie attaque l'Ukraine et que l'Ukraine, on aide l'Ukraine et qu'on affaiblisse comme ça la Russie.
Oui, il y a des intérêts géostratégiques derrière cette guerre et ils se font aux dépens du peuple ukrainien. C'est ça qui est terrible.
Il y a des gens qui se battent aujourd'hui, mais qui le font avec des agendas différents, avec, derrière, des agendas géostratégiques qui ne sont malheureusement pas ceux qui sont dans l'intérêt du peuple ukrainien.
L'avenir nous le dira. Merci beaucoup, David Pestieau, pour ces un peu plus que septante minutes passées ensemble. Je rappelle que vous êtes donc le huitième candidat effectif pour le PTB sur les listes des élections européennes.
Encore merci pour ces septante minutes et je vous dis à très bientôt pour un nouvel épisode.
Merci, au revoir.
J'espère que ça vous a plu. Je pense qu'on a réussi à discuter à la fois des convictions marxistes du parti et aussi de ce qui apparaît comme troublant, hein.
Je pense au rapport au secret, au rapport à la propagande, à l'enrôlement et à la formation des membres et surtout, voilà, leur position vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine, comme vous avez pu l'entendre.
Je précise qu'on a enregistré cet épisode le 18 avril, soit deux jours avant que le Congrès américain approuve la libération d'un budget de soixante milliards,
soixante milliards de dollars, pour soutenir l'Ukraine logistiquement et militairement.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a permis d'apprendre des choses. Est-ce qu'il vous a conforté dans vos convictions ? Est-ce que ça vous a un peu fait changer d'avis en l'écoutant ?
Je ne sais pas. N'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir sur les réseaux sociaux. Tous les liens sont en description. Ça m'intéresse vraiment, très sincèrement, d'avoir vos retours sur cet épisode.
Comme discuté avec David Pestieau, j'ai mis en description le lien vers l'article du Foreign Affairs sur les fameuses négociations qui étaient, semble-t-il, proches d'arriver à la signature d'un traité de paix entre l'Ukraine et la Russie.
C'est vraiment un très bel article. Je remercie David Pestieau de l'avoir mis sur mon radar. Après,
voilà, c'est un article qui est bien plus nuancé et bien plus prudent que ce que David Pestieau a pu présenter pendant l'entretien, je pense.
Il semble que, en effet, l'Ukraine et la Russie étaient persuadées en mars 2022 qu'un traité de paix allait pouvoir être signé avant la fin du mois.
Mais voilà, dans l'article, il y a littéralement la phrase, enfin, un paragraphe qui commence avec la phrase : « L'affirmation que l'Occident a forcé l'Ukraine à se retirer des discussions avec la Russie n'est basée sur rien.
» Voilà. Bref, il reste une part de spéculation importante, mais l'article explique vraiment très bien ce qui a pu jouer dans la décision de Vladimir Zelensky ce jour-là.
L'article est vraiment intéressant. Allez lire si ça vous intéresse, c'est en anglais.
Enfin, si la question du populisme sur les réseaux sociaux, sur les publicités Facebook, etc., vous intéresse, vous pouvez remonter cinq ans en arrière et écouter l'interview qu'on avait faite
avec Patrick Béja et Giuliano Da Empoli à l'époque sur Les ingénieurs du chaos, ça s'appelait.
C'était le titre de son livre. Vous allez pouvoir entendre ma voix de quand j'avais vingt-quatre ans, mais l'épisode est cool malgré ça.
Merci pour votre fidélité. Je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut salut.